hi I'm Erik Bosse an Avengers end game
now officially the most profitable film
of all time
nearly ended with one of the darkest
most tough twists that would have
triggered screams of Terror from
millions of children and millions of
grown men who like toys too much at
comic-con 2019 before Marvel Studios
broke the internet by having Natalie
Portman hold up a hammer from her shell
ally put on a hat and saying more or
less nothing about the Fantastic Four
were black panther or spider-man before
all this the writers of Avengers endgame
Christopher Markus Stephen McFeely spoke
at a fascinating panel that revealed a
number of deleted scenes alternate
versions of the script and concepts that
were rejected the most interesting of
them was an alternate final act the
Battle of Earth as they're calling it in
which 2014 Thanos arrived to the present
day thanks to evil nebulas swapping in
and blasting him up through the quantum
tunnel and then [ __ ] it's real dark now
the screenwriters go into more detail
about this and the commentary track for
the Avengers in-game blu-ray release but
here's what we learned about this darker
alternate Indian at the Comic Con panel
said the wildest thing your earliest
iteration was famous literally walking
out now and throwing down the head of
decapitated Captain America from 2012
yeah he had knowing it would take his
nebulous some time to go rejiggered the
time machine to bring him back so he
went down to his present day yikes
the severed head of Steve Rogers people
dannis was about to go full Game of
Thrones but I guess with an ending with
actual catharsis and the saddest thing
is poor Captain America would have just
gotten his ass beaten by an older
version of himself from the future a
couple years earlier and he would have
spent the time since scratching his head
over what the hell happened back then
was it low-key how do they know Bucky
was still alive is there a clone of me
somewhere out there with the stolen
scepter still
who I know stared at my ass after
knocking me out then yeah sure this is
all assuming that the 2014 timeline that
Thanos and nebula were in was the same
change reality that cap was in a 2012 as
opposed to either of these altered
histories already splitting off its new
branch timelines I know the way time
travel works in the end game is
confusing but don't worry the
screenwriters and directors don't really
get it either but just imagine what it
would have looked like Thanos arriving
to earth back in 2014 where was everyone
then well the Avengers were still all on
the same team remember they were hunting
down hydras forces leading up to the
events of Avengers age of Ultron and
this would be before Ultron arrived so
Stark would still have his iron Legion
at full capacity but of course a vision
did not yet exist in the Maximoff twins
were still in Hydra control and one
Maxima still had a consistently russian
accent it's also worth noting that this
is actor shield would have been exposed
as having been corrupted by Hydra so in
2014 world security forces born in great
shape and back in 2014 what kinda wasn't
yet the public world power that it came
out as years later so I don't know even
with the Avengers working together earth
and 2014 was extremely vulnerable and I
could definitely see daños and his
forces totally clean waste to it sadly I
could also see cap making the kind of
last man standing charge at Thanos as he
did an infinity war and an end game but
the mad Titan getting one clean swing of
that sword and poppy and caps head right
off the fact that Thanos would then
bring this rotting severed head into the
future with him as a kind of trophy or
an intimidation tactic tells us a lot
about the Genghis Khan style Conqueror
past Thanos was and how the older Thanos
by comparison the one infinity war the
one who got decapitated himself was more
of a holy warrior it's also interesting
to think about this alternate sequence
and remember the deleted scene from
Infinity Ward the flashback in which
Gamora
brought the severed head of a conquered
King interrupted at thanasis beat Sara
died King
eternal loyalty to your cause except in
my terms
yeah guy likes his heads and this would
have been in addition to deleted dark
images from infinity war which would
have shown Bannos walking among the
river of hood after snapping his fingers
and another that we just found out about
that would have shown Panos revisiting
all of his dead victims in a Doctor
Strange induced mind now thankfully this
is as dark as the end game screenwriters
let their imaginations go oh wait
there's another one good God giant mans
course if these Marvel movies are all of
us playing with toys as adults these
dudes were Sid the old man Logan comic
that they're referring to is one of the
bleakest comic storylines that actually
partially inspired the film Logan but in
the comic an elderly version of
Wolverine goes on a road trip with
Hawkeye who's now blind in a
post-apocalyptic landscape after most of
the superheroes are dead Wolverine
actually killed all of the x-men biggest
Mysterio tricked him with an illusion to
think they were all enemies and Hulk is
an evil slumlord as I said bleak and one
of the most haunting visuals from this
storyline was a two-page spread showing
the colossal skeleton of Hank Pym giant
man stretched across the frozen
landscape with a tiny highway winding in
a shadow of his mountainous rotting
bones yeah nothing's worse than a giant
dead corpse left to bloat and rot all
over acres and acres a similar thing
actually happened in the Civil War
comics with Goliath yeah yeah what do
you do in that situation and I hate to
keep bringing this up folks but people
do [ __ ] themselves when they die so
there's that I guess you'd have to like
TNT the rotting flesh like a deadbeat
whale so this is the image the writers
wanted in the background of end game
behind Thanos presumably in an earlier
version of time-travel in that movie
where the maybe the previous time is so
visible in the background details on the
other side of a portal or something
Thanos walks in with caps severed head
punts it points to giant Michael Douglas
because remember in 2014 Scott Lang
wasn't yet ant-man so giant Michael
Douglas his [ __ ] covered corpse strewn
across the Brooklyn Bridge or something
with Thanos sane businesswoman
gonna do to you yeah you know what now
that I'm picturing this offenders
savegames the final battle could have
been a lot cooler if they did this but
do you think in game's final battle
should have been this dark comment down
below with your thoughts and follow me
on instagram twitter at da vas and
subscribe the new rock stars from
breakdowns of everything you need to
know about Marvel thank you for joining
me and I cannot wait to hear the writers
other deleted scene from the end game
final battle in which Stannis makes a
kebab but with the corpses of Peter
Parker and Cherie and Morgan Stark and
then like roast them over the flames of
Hawkeye's farm want too dark
[Music]